hey huge show coming up so those who
still have social media accounts blasted
out subscribe to the channel hit the
notification bail because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot and that way you
can see a video immediately before it's
removed of course subscribe on iTunes or
SoundCloud for when you're on the go and
I know we've talked about it for a long
time
lotto credit a calm slash mug club but
we need you now more than ever to help
support our fight and because we want
you to see that it's worth it
we're offering a 30 day free trial right
now start now a lot of Canada comes last
mile clip 30-day free trial enjoy the
show
this coffee you've built put a platform
for yourself detective
you should be very [ __ ] the hell up you
piece of [ __ ]
California stay away from here stay away
from here don't come anywhere near here
appeal has the upper hand here you come
what I wish I could have looked like you
sure you're talking about
you hear me detective in fact I'm trying
to tell you how much I admire you and
your your pretty much what nut cut
what'd you find disturbing how easy it
is to remember men set to join my club
for the fake student ID
I visited your studio this morning after
you left danced a BOGO try to taste the
life of it strange animal didn't work
out so I left a souvenir my pretty
tumbler give me the gun going on over
there put the gun down I saw you with
the box what's in the box that is said I
envied honey life seems that Envy is my
skin no one from the bar give me the gun
Stephen what did a big box he just told
you what he wants it wants you to shoot
him become vengeance counts give me the
gun yeah you should have Jewish lawyer
Stephen you'll be tied up at Cole for
decades and he was spending a Peter back
to the marks condition detective and for
his work visa
shut up I had promptly Republican up
oh he didn't know
[Music]
Stephen if you kill him he will win oh
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
come on we can take it we can take it
that's the sound of the week and we can
take it we can take it you Twitter and
you had YouTube sons of bits I right off
the bat it's been a tough week I've been
doing the guided meditation my doctor
started because I'm too stressed and
then I listened to this stuff like I'm
SoundCloud I have a playlist and the guy
who's talking release your breath think
of nothing I'm on this guy's being paid
to tell me to not think and then I get
mad may call my doctor you say geology
professor point College professors I
have no idea I don't know he's trying to
get me banned from SMU we have Paul
Joseph Watson the show a prison planet
on the show today and then of course we
have a update with my lawyer bill
Richman a lot of big stuff going on with
the Twitter's with the youtubes and some
things that we can't necessarily mention
but we'll talk about next week at SMU
March 22nd producing a mean video studio
you can follow him on twitter at not gay
Jared I'd say me it's Crowder but yeah I
can't talk to you right now you're
photoshop's your comments your videos I
fulfill my league obligations during
inclusions are we good we good you know
Twitter jail cuisine nothing but Zoe
what are jail cuisine nothing but the
soy that makes sense yeah I think that
that should be cuisine in jail jail hmm
I don't understand the logic behind
giving them protein to make them
stronger
give them uteruses yeah that's better
let's send them back into society weaker
than when they went in estrogen at G
Morgan Jr simplified one come with one
of the day one of the day continuing the
theme capture capture I see what you did
there that's like when you capture the
gaze of a studly man or somebody and you
ready for the the research the overlay
is there spend computer and you're the
one who got us into this mess so thank
you Thank You Sven collector
told you you'd be a legend just not the
way you thought so uh we're by the way
are we talking with Richmond we're gonna
be getting this video back up somehow if
you're watching on YouTube and you
missed the video join my club you can
watch it there anything else is there
for now they're threatening us with the
legal action but we don't follow
YouTube's policy we follow the actual
law we follow the law YouTube
Fall Out Boy has announced an anti-gun
concert for the March for our lives
rally with Pete Wentz claiming we want
to be the soundtrack for gun control
so do we please everyone when you think
of modern-day when you think of the
modern-day gun control movement suddenly
think of these guys so do we actually
says nothing to do with their lack of
relevance for the last decade no yes
accounting nothing no you're right yes
fallout but when it comes to saying no
to guns and gun related imagery you'll
be number one with a bullet a loaded gun
complex [ __ ] it and pull it in your
mouth we will sort of count it to make
sure that you are the face of the gun
control mood by the way in the least
surprising news of the day a baker from
France has been fined 3000 euros for
working too much a baker from the small
town of losing either Don's in your vows
and I'm French I can't read it in
northeastern France was fined 3,000
euros for working seven days a week the
law imposing a weekly day of rest for
all workers but said toothache aveva
have kept his bakery open all week in
the summer of 2017 hem and we got a
scoop I think I actually think to
discuss this because it's confusing to a
lot of Americans is um the ambassador to
the United States ambassador French
thank you for being here sir yes of
course
Stephen so you find this man 3,000 euros
just for working on a Sunday
do I guess well you see he broke the law
you can't work seven days a week that is
the law in France and without laws we
are just like you see just like the
animals this interesting I thought
France was largely secular so enforcing
the Sabbath laws was surprising to me
I'm sorry what was that this the Sabbath
laws no no your confuses there are no
sad baths in France because here in
France we don't take baths little on the
nose no Sabbath the day of rest you
don't work on the Sabbath oh okay no
yeah I understand now this law does not
come from some archaic religion no no no
no no you see it's because we are how
you say lazy okay thank you mr.
ambassador French I contribute nothing
Stephen I know thank you
I wish that would have gone better but I
didn't expect it to it's about like this
week and Oklahoma mom there's other news
and we're going to be talking about some
more legal issues with social home in
India I feel like we need to Oklahoma
watch at this point now I think we need
more of an India watch more of India
watch for sure I know watches to have at
this point really well except they don't
have watches in India the technology
isn't really there waiting for that well
not only the watches the wheel hasn't
gotten there so if they sell watch they
would know what to do with it and banned
in Oklahoma mom who actually once
married her son this is a real story
will now go to jail for marrying her
daughter this comes from WFA for her
part in marrying her daughter two years
after she was legally allowed to contact
her children following in an old
marriage to her biological son Patricia
span will serve time in jail so the
interesting part is a detaining officer
released a statement that Patricia span
will receive quote eight years probation
for the crime of felony incest then he
clarified the crime of felony lesbian
incest and he was immediately banned
from Twitter first upon hearing the news
Farah Khan himself blamed the filthy
Jews yeah that's not a that's an actual
Twitter that's verified it's not liable
for his account no one took over his
with them Twitter tested Jack approved
yeah there's a chick with some serious
daddy / broader issue Dean came fans
they both had Superman shirts on did
they they did in the picture they just
think we have a super relationship it's
gonna serve eight years for felony
incest but save a ton on last name
paperwork that's true why can't you just
marry your son like a decent person
sorry start doing that lesbian things
got out of hand
you need a tweet we are not animals
ki brother is perfectly good just right
your grandpa had a flipper your Pappy
had a flipper for him United Airlines by
the way accidentally flew a German
Shepherd to Japan instead of Kansas yeah
that's a story comes from Newsweek cuz
when cross window arrived at Kansas City
Airport the family went to cut the cargo
facility to pick up at any old German
Shepherd
ergo instead of their dog the swindle
family were handed a Great Dane who was
scheduled to fly to Japan wait his
family's in Kansas and he's in Japan
wait his family's in Kansas and he the
luck of that dog to land his ass in the
one agent country that doesn't see him
is fine cuisine you could have so easily
been rerouted to Vietnam China or Korea
or Thailand or Indonesia I think that
Disney film would be all dogs go to
kettle and then Tommy learn would kick
them what's what's the story Tommy one
kicked same computer you were telling me
that's Tommy one kicked the dog
she's now denying it but you had the
video on a social media saying that she
kicked her dog because the dog
interrupted her doing an interview on
Fox & Friends
so she rating she she read it away yeah
she did she shoot away she said I had to
kick you five times oh five time and you
know there's video graphic evidence
because they have the leg cam yeah this
is the one time a producer in the
control room at Fox is going get off the
white chair get up get down [ __ ] off
like though the other [ __ ] no no notnot
the dog dog get the dog are you saying
want to see your gams no I'm saying the
opposite of that
I'm confused I don't understand what
don't you want this is literally the
first time I've ever ever words in that
order out of your mouth sorry Tommy
sorry watch this show this was sent to
her if it's not banned Ford is now by
the way for go out there we want to do a
public service Ford is recalling 1.4
million cars which you know sometimes is
like because the sometimes they're
problems a brake pad you sometimes you
have a circuit board that's because
steering wheels are coming off seems
important yeah kind of pivotal see this
is what I hate the idea of be American
where was Abby American Baia Mare and
I've always be American buy the best and
and sometimes the best is an
american-made okay sometimes even that
sometimes american-made can
you may see the boy that's american-made
steel that is from American union
workers American man you can't put a
price on our simple art in the White
House
I'll obey that waiting I will be done I
guess also Lincoln's by the way we
should do that if for anyone who's out
there actually taking this I imagine the
worst part of this whole thing is having
the air to plug deploy deploy a new Air
drag I don't know I don't know I guess
this is a new this is the new safety
device that we haven't heard of yeah
it'll be because Ford just put it in
there instead of a steering wheel
all right listen do you know what can I
do we usually do a meat segment we get
any we have a ton of research and this
has been a stressful week for people who
don't know I've been Twitter banned for
the video we sent it by the way fun
computer thank you for going to need a
great job with that really I think you
did a great job for people who want to
watch it go to mug Club did you guys
mind if I take take a fitting that's
usually we go we go into something we
say let's dive into a topic and people
use it to to educate themselves and
educate their professors and use it to
rebut maybe Vox on gun control so we ask
you a question first off because we've
been dealing with it this week do you
feel there's a generation gap between
those in the social media fray right now
the ones who are obviously censoring
different points of view right of center
points of view and the old conservative
guard because that's what I've been
running into I have not been as upset
what you expect this from the left
people been saying for example that
Twitter and YouTube they shouldn't have
banned the video but then we've had a
lot of conservatives this week who've
been criticizing us saying well sure it
was entertaining but really how
constructive was it I wrote I wrote I
read somebody writing that it was
entertaining but was it constructive to
send in some computer to the gender
nonconforming it was entertaining but
was it constructive you just answered
your own damn question the point you
missed it was it exactly was energy
that's the point you're talking by the
way to the creators have changed my mind
were millions upon millions of plays of
nothing more than me sitting down with a
stool in enemy territory being bombarded
and trying to be as constructive as
humanly possible by the way this is a
late night show do you think anyone has
ever asked
I don't know how constructive it is for
Carson to do there's old tarp it I don't
know how constructive Letterman's top 10
is you know we don't want to be
constructive all the time so that's what
they say if you're talking about we're
talking about the banning we're talking
about the legal issues we'll talk more
about that with bill Richman after
you're either in or you're out you
understand how this works or you don't
whether you whether you support the idea
of the content or not and these concerns
we run into you guys all the time you
[ __ ] and you say why does Jimmy Kimmel
get to use his platform for politics I'm
not gonna tune in to the Oscars but you
know why because he spent years being
entertaining if people are going to hold
us to that standard where every single
thing we say has to be like Rush
Limbaugh's cheering on Dear Leader let
me you were not the show for you was it
constructive it was hysterical
I pissed myself laughing and if that's
what determines whether you support us
or these people support us not in
fighting these behemoths of fascist
censorship bastions about all ism okay
then piss off don't want your show how's
that for constructive I expect this I
expect this from the left I expect them
to try and silence us but the see
conservatives going well I would support
you if you didn't do something that was
a could it be a little more constructive
could it be a lecture by the way as far
as constructive there's a reason this
video was removed the left understands
the scope of what we're doing okay the
old stick-in-the-mud right vanguard has
no idea you bet your ass the left thinks
it's constructive that's why they had a
hair-trigger double-barreled machine gun
ready for all of the platforms to remove
this video because they realize how
constructive it was in making the left
looking like the silly lgbtq a AIP too
spirited dumbasses that they are that's
why we don't like to talk about our
numbers we don't go out and brag that's
not what we're based on we've been
focusing on content creating more
content than ever but we cannot hire
people fast enough to keep up with the
growth which is a blessing and for which
we are eternally grateful but that's
because we were too busy being
unconstructive while you were
sermonizing to 85 year old geriatrics
who want to stock up on self lubricating
pocket catheters the left understands
how dangerous we are and all they do is
run a clip of the latest consumed by the
way the latest ranked the latest concern
right or got you segment on Fox and
Friends they just run on the view and go
see ha they just run the latest NRA clip
and go see they don't even need to rebut
it they just hit play and laugh if you
think that's constructive that's what
they do to conservatives constructive
content but it's just like what we do on
the flip side with Samantha bee or
Trevor Noah
we don't need to rebut it there there
unfunniest is their own rebuttal now
guess who these leftist sites never roll
us our content will get falls more play
this is a table break what content will
get fooled war plays then these hosts on
the left then the kimmells then the Seth
Meyers
then the Jimmy Fallon's with a fraction
and I mean fraction of the staff and I
mean a fantastic staff but we are
talking pennies on the dollar when
you're talking about higher ease
employees and the left doesn't play it
oh here's the thing they try to remove
it behind the seams they Twitter BAM
like you saw they Facebook throttle they
try to get dozens of videos removed from
our channel on YouTube we deal with this
all the time but they never ever utter
the phrase or the words louder with
Crowder for the left were like Candyman
they're afraid if they say our name
three times in the mirror will show up
and rape them with their own power tools
mind you their own power tools of
entertainment and comedy and by the way
we will we will show up and sexually a
cost level speaking of this
metaphorically of course
the left I'm speaking metaphorically of
course we will show up we will do this
and we do it we do so many things we
have a lawyer on retainer to fight this
every dollar you give us every dollar
you spend that goes into mud club goes
into providing more free content and
making sure that the path is still open
for you we're not like the Sarah
Silverman's we're not like the Amy
Schumer's we're not like the shock jock
comics who go up and they do a bunch of
dirty jokes and then they say you know
what you really shouldn't say gay we
opened the door behind us and we hope
that you can draft in and we do it for
you yeah you know it's been a really
stressful week hell it's been a really
stressful year but only for the
stressful week for us just as much
really I would say more so because of
the old conservative guard as it's been
for the left trying to silence us which
is why we're so grateful for people like
you who do watch and who do share and
who do do join over there mush watch I
said you watch there's gonna be another
daily storm or thing and then other
teachers are trying to be banned from
SMU this week it's been Twitter it's
been YouTube it's been Facebook which
you don't even know about it's been
South by Southwest you bet your
ask that we've had a rough go but every
dollar we get from you joining Mudd Club
that we get from you supporting the
sponsors buying the merch we'll go to
fighting this with everything we got
because despite the fact we have a
giant-ass target on our back we know
that you have ours and who cares if the
old stodgy Republicans don't have your
back we do we do this is where we are
this week it's been stressful but it's
also been a relief let me ask you do you
have values that don't wind up with your
professors maybe if you're in college
you're a college student we know we
won't look at our demographics maybe
your values don't line up with your
peers maybe it doesn't line up with a
social media elite you feel like you
don't quite fit in with the the Oscars
elite crowd but you're also maybe not
welcome at the young Republican parties
and conventions you feel like a misfit
you're tired of fighting the whole damn
world and you wish there are people out
there like you well here we are here we
are we've got food we've got beer laughs
guns and mugs and you're welcome to stay
as long as you want and if that doesn't
seem kosher to you feeling that's not
constructive if you're not willing to
take up arms and grow a pair this just
isn't the place for you how about that
hit the unsubscribe button if you want
to fight if you'll want to show your war
face subscribe join my club hit the
notification button because that way you
at least see it before it gets taken
down within minutes and we will be
talking with Paul Joseph Watson and then
our lawyer to update you I'm sorry I
hopefully I've earned the right to do
that every now and then
[Music]
[Music]
by the way that is the toughest man
you've ever seen wearing a girdle as the
San Francisco before the removing of the
video from the YouTube before the stuff
that's happened with Facebook that we
can't exactly talk about before the
temporary Twitter ban which could be a
permanent ban I threw out my back
did entirely dick move anyway
our next guest I love him he's a sweet
looking chap I think that's what they
call him over there it's been a while
since he's been on and he's also been at
the this the end of the rifle of uh I
guess what would cut what would we call
it big tech I don't know you follow him
you love him on Twitter at prison planet
how are you mr. Watson I am good Steve
and good to be back well I don't that
doesn't sound convincing at all so hey
first question why do you keep the map
seems to get increasingly wrinkly it's
you needs ironing it needs ironing it's
because I keep moving house and I keep
having to fold it up and then unpack it
again so it needs irony is this because
you had to like because you had to move
out due to the Muslim encroachment of
your previous neighborhood no I live in
exactly the same neighborhoods just
moved to a place just rebuttal the
flatterer theorist yes exactly I am from
year to year to evade detection from you
know tolerant peaceful liberals yeah
well the catch-22 is if you want to
carry a firearm in the United States you
have to list your new address anyway so
I'm not listed but there's a projectile
carrying a firearm don't worry yes I
know because you're in a land where you
have no freedom Paul uh have you been
sing about Paul Watson Paul Joseph was
missing the Jos I can't think of a more
English sounding name is that like I
mean I was gonna say is that like John
Smith over there in the UK but that I
suppose that would just be John Smith
well I only used I used the middle name
because Paul Watson is that big
environmentalist sea Shepherd guy so I
have two different he probably hates me
by the way yes I'm sure he does Joseph
steven crowder calm yeah there was a guy
who went Steven credit I tried to shake
me down for tens of thousands of dollars
and then said hey man we both come to
the same cross I was like what your
cross ism prick yeah I try to pull the
Christian Cardinals like okay well yeah
we're like so one hundred million
dollars all right Paul what what have
you
Haddix what have you experienced
yourself as it comes to YouTube and
Twitter and Facebook you've been pretty
good for the most part I don't think
you've had a ton of suspensions or
removals right um what I'm finding now
is like I dig back through old videos on
YouTube so for example it's like almost
two years ago I made a video called F
the Pope went back and they put it in
limited state you know right and what
that is they put it behind like a wall
where nobody can find it unless they got
the direct link so they don't even send
you an email they don't even notify you
say oh this videos disappeared this
videos disappeared there was one about
Trump retweeting Britain first and the
first sentence was Trump was dumb for
retweeting Britain first band appealed
it it came back after he got like
national newspaper attention I went back
like two days ago
he's being banned again so even videos
that have been appealed in a back online
they banned them a secondly this was
banned because he said Trump is dumb I
think he was just Britain first in the
headline of the video the reason it was
banned why now they're like if you put
hey if the iPod I hate pineapple Peaks
are in the title of a video that's
banned because you gonna have hate in
the title it's getting increasingly
insane there was a tweet I put out today
you know people on Twitter who like your
YouTube video the one that got you in
the big trouble yeah I know they're
already they're all getting automates a
tweet like it's not even they haven't
even written it's like if you like a
video on YouTube automatically tweets
you liked the video banned for seven
days I know by the way please can you
help us and a tweet obviously this out
tonight but let them know because I
can't none of us can I think not gay
Jared can tweet now I always Banford let
them know to not tweet it out we
appreciate them on it but please do not
support us and post this video you will
get Twitter banned just for liking our
video to the Internet the thing you know
the thing that annoys me about all this
right this all came down the pipeline
after Charlotte's feel about the
contrived hysteria over the alt right
you know they all write the actual all
right which the less thinks is everyone
right of Michael Moore but it isn't the
actual alt right they don't get affected
by the censorship if their YouTube
channel gets taken down they've got such
a tiny platform to begin with right they
just start a new channel and
even notices I mean this is the point I
make over and over again the left loves
the old right because they use them as a
stick to bashes over the head with you
know you can Richard Spencer has a
speech there's more cameras in the
audience than people in the audience I
mean they're only platform is the
mainstream media right the mainstream
media loves them because they use them
to bash us to you know portray us as
extremists we just talked about at SMU
this pretty this UT Arlington professor
who was posting these saying we need to
get him back we need to get him banned
from SMU was posting fake memes of me
posted by the was a storm I don't know
daily stormer because they thought it
was Jewish right because I support
Israel's right to exist so they did a
bunch of antisymmetric means and then
when people found out I wasn't Jewish
they said oh let's tattoo swastika on
him and Photoshop it and have a whole
bunch of anti-semitic memes and racist
memes to try and ruin his career this
guy by the way I I don't go around
filing filing violations in social media
willy-nilly
that's libel that's illegal to do right
saying steven crowder said kill all the
n-words or whatever it is that they say
and I go hey I didn't say that that
can't be up their Twitter manually
reviewed it said it's okay and a
professor is now using it to try and get
me banned from campus it's not are there
standards and do conservatives
conservatives violate the standards of
Twitter fine if conservatives violated
standards of YouTube because they just
said we don't want your point of view
they can do that it is about standards
being applied equally that is the
standard that is the measurement for law
is it applied equally sorry Jared you
were gonna say sauce and if they're also
offensively poor photoshop's
I just wanna throw that out there
professor the one about Twitter writing
your aunt coffee and then later banning
banning back we literally have a paper
trail a mile long of them going hey you
should advertise with us
I don't know well if you advertise with
us the great thing about Twitter is you
get to you get to keep Fayed 12
followers you getting to do the same
thing they do the same thing everywhere
else all these social media sites like
well I don't know well let's get you on
with one of our Twitter social media
expert analysts who just came out of
college and he goes yeah but what would
you like to write and I don't know
should let me try out five of these yeah
those are good
let's sample those and find out which
ones are most effective hey great news
this one's most effective do you give me
the authorization to increase the budget
sure by the way it's no that is the most
egregious and plain stupid example I
think I've ever heard about I mean the
point is the wider point there was a you
know Niall Ferguson noted British
historian gave a talk a few days ago he
came out and said look Trump would not
have won the election without Facebook
in the past six weeks or even less
Trump's lost forty five percent of his
Facebook engagement traffic there was a
Western Journalism study that came out a
couple of days ago liberal sites are
plus two since the Facebook algorithm
change conservative sites are minus
fourteen percent in terms of engagement
right if you take Fox News out of the
equation for whatever reason they've
gone way up over the past six weeks you
take them out at times well with
conservative sites on Facebook are down
in terms of engagement traffic 32% yeah
this is gonna decide elections this is
what Niall Ferguson said in his talk
this will decide election Silicon Valley
is now deciding election well here's the
it's a very important point and actually
the Western journalism guys were asking
to come on this show but um not
necessarily the most entertaining folks
we're like let's let's let's find a
pocket for you later uh but uh yet the
important thing there is not just Donald
Trump because people can say well he's
made some bad decisions he's pissed off
conservatives but like you said across
the board and also people could say
midterms right midterms obviously the
opposition party tends to do better but
across the board for conservatives not
only conservatives of this includes
libertarians this includes people like
us comedians who just happen to be right
of center doing more poorly and it
doesn't correlate with the television
numbers by the way of some of these
other pages that's what's important it
is not consistent at all it clearly is
and by the way
Gizmodo and gadget they wrote that
article where it was admitted from
Facebook we dealt with them out of court
they admitted to manually throttling my
page here's my question to you Paul cuz
obviously you work under the the bigger
umbrella with Infowars people know you
we don't want to people just we have a
lawyer on retainer right we've learned
that we have one of the top 100 lawyers
in all of Texas period on retainer we
made it
part of our business model because we
said we know this is coming it doesn't
help conservatives for people to just
[ __ ] and then not take legal action I
know you guys have have have taken some
actions right I mean what would you
advise people do if this this kind of
thing happens we've got to make it sting
and we've got to make it sting together
you've got to take legal action like
this has been a relentless purge it's
all still based on that butter but over
the election but over the last few
months its lawsuit after lawsuit like we
get won almost every week now they're
all frivolous it's like the Pepe the
Frog creator saying that we violated his
copyright oh but you gave an interview
in 2015 saying everyone can profit off
of Pepe the Frog so there's a poster
with pepper in it we weed in even design
it we sell it that's frivolous you know
we've got all kinds of stuff going on
there it's keeping us on the ropes and
quite frankly this is boring to have to
whine about how rain censored every
single day people get so jaded of it so
people should probably just spend more
time and focus on the lawsuits
I talked to Alan Bakari Breitbart senior
tech editor you know we were talking
about a March in DC's like well everyone
has a March in DC every Saturday but
it's not even gonna make a make a mark
why not a big March in Silicon Valley on
Google or on Facebook has one strand of
you know a plan of action why not
pressure lawmakers this is what he said
to me and he's talking to these people
lawmakers aren't hearing about this
constituents conservatives aren't
bitching about it enough to get it in
front of them well they are worrying but
they're bitching about it just saying oh
this this happened I will tell you I
feel like Michael Douglas and falling
down because I've gotten some emails
from people going like hey welcome to
the club now you're like us and I'm
sitting there going I am nothing like
you I am nothing like you we have a I
don't we don't we that's why we did
[ __ ] Bane and jihadi bond that's what
we just started mug club we said you
know what we're not gonna sit and piss
and moan we're going to get active
that's what we're doing today we're
gonna have a parody of Seven Brides for
Seven Brothers next week
we're gonna have the biggest show we've
ever had in our lives at SMU with over
2,000 people focus on the content but
take the legal action and unfortunately
you're one of the only other people have
seen do this you mention it when it's
important but unfortunately a lot of
conservatives out there
turn their content into nothing but
bitching about it I think you do it once
then take the legal action and continue
with content
because that's how you win exactly and
set the precedent and Democratic
lawmakers this is shoved in front of
them all the time like they're actively
talking to Twitter executives there was
a case during the shortly after the
October 31st attack in New York where it
was a Democratic congressman bitching
about how my Infowars story was at the
top of the twitter search trend for that
day it was based on a story an imam in
new york warned de Blasio that
radicalization was taking place in
mosques in New York completely accurate
story he did warn him
he provided the letter the congressman
was like how on earth does this get to
the top of Twitter and the Twitter
exactly was like yeah well it was gone
by lunchtime don't worry about it
so you have been putting pressure on
Twitter every available opportunity
that's not happening on the right and
that was one thing with Ted Cruz last
month with this Communications Decency
Act which says they have to abide by
being politically neutral or they lose
legal immunity for uses of content so if
someone posts a death rot on YouTube
YouTube is responsible for it right I
mean that's one way to go we have to get
it in front of lawmakers and not just
whine about it on Twitter and we have a
half-asian lawyer who will be up after
this to talk about what we're doing
because yeah listen I've been against
this people say need to be regulated
like a public utility right like telecom
companies and I said no my solution
isn't big government but I'm at the
point now where when they claim hey yeah
yeah we don't we don't want to we don't
want to have those regulations but we
are politically neutral when they click
when they go out and they court people
to spend money with them listen if you
spend a million dollars with YouTube and
Twitter and Facebook which by the way is
not unheard of let's say some what
people talk about the Bush tax cuts they
got some and 50,000 more a million
dollars in growth and advertising spent
over the course of five years it's not
much and a lot of people right now are
advised to spend that on social media
advertising that is a million dollars
they could spend somewhere else in
inventory and they're spending it based
on a lie like you said I don't know they
might need to be regulated as public
utility companies they might need to be
I might be changing my mind on this
before we go Paul can you do me one
favor can you say I ate lunch at Google
I ate lunch at Google I don't know
I just I feel like I'm in a Beatles jam
session Americans and Canadians can't
tell the difference between different
British acts I do I know it's Liverpool
there's a vast difference I know there's
a big difference because when a guy
there was a fighter named Terry Adam
from Liverpool and when he got up on the
microphone after winning a fight and
started speaking I about pissed myself
laughing it was so funny but there there
I get I mean there's Manchester as more
working class and there's London I
understand um Paul so what so what do
they do you say go to their lawmakers so
we're doing what we can specifically
with our cases not everyone has a paper
trail of Twitter taking money and then
saying hey this is a violation of our
policy what can the average person do
who's in the right who isn't violating
copyright how can they fight back you
talk about getting in front of
legislators what can they do you've
talked about this well I think bagon a
star campaign which is basically a you
know a stock form that they can fill in
and insert their own particular
relevance into it so we need to do that
we need to except a process where it's
automated I mean that's what the left
does we need to organize that's what
they're good at that's what we're
terrible that we need to communicate
what I saw after the CNN thing where
they literally lobbied to shut down our
YouTube channel they were talking to
YouTube like oh what about this video
what about this video then I had CNN
people coming back at me saying oh we're
just covering the story no you know
you're in there directly communicating
with YouTube execs with particular
videos that you claim a hate speech or
whatever this is a lobbying campaign so
I mean right after that I said we need
to declare war on the mainstream media
they had a video where they harassed a
woman outside her own home an elderly
woman in Florida
clearly harassment clearly daxing that
videos up on YouTube nothing whatsoever
happens so right you said we need to
strike back also with the
telecommunications thing the regulation
if you have a phone contract with the
t-mobile or whoever they don't get to
ban your contract because they don't
like the content of your conversations
that you have with people on the phone
so I'm warming more towards some kind of
regulation maybe some kind of Internet
bill of rights there's another way to go
I think we should have this
on to it I think Twitter YouTube and
Facebook should be given the option you
don't have to but if you lose your
immunity right you lose your immunity
here if you don't sign on to okay we are
a politically neutral platform you allow
it into a full deeply-rooted
investigation so we know that your
algorithms are fair we get to do a full
manual review or or you don't get to
play nice or you don't get down that's
what needs to happen they have to choose
they can't leave right now they're
having best of all worlds and by the way
for people out there obey the law these
people have their own pot like YouTube
is a good example right they said well
someone complained it was a violation of
privacy
well we recorded South by Southwest
where it's a single party consent state
and actually they allow you to film at
some of these events for the first five
minutes particularly at meetups either
way the law says you can't
well they say our policy says you can't
because somebody isn't like what they
did well by by investigative journalism
meanwhile libelous videos or claims like
for example videos that they're saying
that I want to exterminate the Jews and
I say can you manually review this and
Twitter says no no that's fine
that is illegal that's actually libel
and slander you can lose in court so
their policies don't follow the law and
they even allow criminal activity to
occur on their platform there needs to
be legal ramifications so I know I hope
you spearhead it along with us and we
this is the shot heard around the world
I mean they would be more sensible to
just do the shadow banning in the
algorithm changes because he can't
really prove either way if that's
happening you know it was a study by
psychologist called Robert Epstein he
found that Google's ranking algorithm in
terms of one candidate versus another
positive stories ranked above negative
stories they could influence the outcome
of 25% of all national elections that is
the power of the algorithm so that's
going to be a big battle as well but
when they target individuals and just
create all this resentment they're gonna
create a rod for their own back the
backlash has already started and it's
gonna get bigger a rod for my back sure
sounds good right now I'd stabilize it
this girl isn't quite doing the whole
trick good point though and it's
shocking that they're doing all of this
they're throttling and they're banning
and they're censoring and we are still
winning the right is still taking it to
them imagine if we weren't being
censored and dragged down by this would
be absolutely crushing them and instead
of being one little nation they don't
right exactly instead of being whiny
[ __ ] like a lot of people out there
are
getting active and by the way like we
said our of the old stodgy conservatives
who don't like it that's fine you don't
have to like it just get out of the way
and let us do our thing Paul Joseph
Watson at prison planet on Twitter
always nice to speak with you sir again
let your fans know do not support that
video don't tweet it out yeah I'll make
sure to let them know Stevens alright we
will be back March 22nd SMU Dallas Texas
prepares the greatest show can I come
inside guys beep beep don't wait
but it's raining out here
[Music]
our AppleCare cover that was it Halle
covers manufacturer hello lot it was
called reviewers hopper here don't
forget the new coalition to the podcast
on the go on iTunes SoundCloud are in
the audio you can download it and you
can listen it
[Music]
[Music]
and Lawson says that song from our
lovely lovely friend Pogo anyone else
it's better to have fought and lost and
that's we say we are we are swinging as
hard as we possibly can that's why even
though we had them on this week a lot of
updates so I want to bring him back on
my half-asian lawyer a good friend of
the show bill Richman how are you sir
doing well
to be here good I'm glad to have you
here now before we move on just so
people kind of understand this first off
how many times have you won or been
awarded the title of best business
lawyer in Dallas three times three times
okay and how many times have you been
among the top 100 young lawyers in all
of Texas period I think it's two times
and are you expensive to have on hire
exceptionally and how much do you just
want to see Twitter and the social media
behemoths pay for their crimes against
humanity I don't know that the words can
adequately describe it but my body
shakes and shakes and shakes when I
think about well good more glad that we
have we have this man on retainer he's a
company I believe I'm not sure but we're
keeping him because we need him it's a
part of our business plan first off let
me ask you what have you done with that
Charles Hermes character he was a
professor or lecturer and I don't know
if there's anything at Utd no UT
Arlington falsely spreading false Nazi
memes of myself to try and get the March
22nd SMU show canceled what have you
done with that with that jump the legal
definition of what I sent was a love
note by staying a retraction and a
correction there's some great things
under Texas law that allow us to say hey
if you make a false statement and you're
causing issues you should make a
retraction or correction if you want to
deal with the issue and so we've given
him an opportunity to do the right thing
and not just delete the tweet or delete
the post but to actually do the right
thing here we'll see we'll see what he
does okay and for the record by the way
it seems like the show is unaffected
March 22nd at SMU thus far but fine
largest because of Twitter has not made
a phone call yet so no Twitter 74 to
quick follow-up questions on that in
Texas where the video that was removed
from YouTube was filmed I just want to
make sure people
just a single party or two-party consent
state okay
another question I guess is when
someone's puts a quote Nexus and says
that you said this thing for example
like kill all the Jews or whatever it is
and knowingly spreads false information
what is the legal term for that
definition or if in writing libel okay
is that illegal it is against the
statutes of this great state okay let me
ask what are we doing with that video
that was removed on YouTube to get it
back on YouTube ax try and play ball and
be as B as to be as as much of a partner
as we can I think we're shooting in the
dark and guessing because no one wants
to actually say with specificity what
the alleged issue is well what the
actual actions were taking are blurring
or blurring things out we're blowing
more things out we're blurring any
possibility of a name or a face of
people who were in a public place
knowingly being filmed were actually
happy they were being filmed until they
realized that they weren't necessarily
being filmed in a particularly friendly
way and then it kind of turned around
right no exactly I should note two
people who don't know who have been
following who aren't mug Club members we
were hit with a privacy violation now
usually if someone says it's a privacy
violation first off you know there's
there's laws and then there's policies
from these social media Jenna what's
crazy is that sometimes they actually go
further than the law even if you're
following law and then sometimes they
allow criminal acts like libel to take
place on their platform after a manual
review so you can't know what's long
what spall hard work the track we were
just told it was a someone complaining
about privacy and the time code then
Todd was the entire village that's the
entire direction of the video so bill I
said listen blur every face every name
okay let's try and play ball all the
things exactly I mean but it's a
shooting in the dark because really the
the way that this system works is they
can only be very you know selective in
their application of the rules if
they're unclear as to what the rules are
because if everyone knew what the rules
were it'd be able to say that's wrong
that's right but what they like to do is
say oh there's no one to talk to there's
no
the rules kind of changed we're not sure
how you interpret our own rules and then
you get situations where people within
the own organization or do whatever they
want and unfortunately what they want is
to silence voices all right right and
exactly like we said to people you want
to keep plugging it but that's why mug
club exists see our TV laterals better
not come / mutt Club we do obey the law
in the way that we create our content
and those are the policies we have so
you can go watch it there because we are
not looking to break the law and we'll
blow everything and track it final
question what exactly are your going to
be doing with Twitter so Twitter was the
video it just said was a violation of
content we all said that was a
long-standing history we talked about
running ads that they helped create and
then banning the ads what what are you
doing with Twitter can you say so we've
got a lovely thing I can say right now
is we're making an all-out effort to be
able to hit them at all channels of
communication to let them know that this
is a serious issue that they have to fix
immediately unfortunately they that's
the policy that they use got a de facto
policy of whoever makes the loudest
noise might get some relief from these
draconian random applications of the
rules and for everything else I'm gonna
have to save it for the March 22nd shown
SMU I'll give an announcement and update
them and kind of reveal a little bit
more once things become more public of
exactly the steps were taking okay so at
SMU March 22nd half-asian lawyer bill
Richman gonna have some major
announcements announcements I forgot my
C's and it's gonna be one hell of a
party thank you Bill we're glad to have
you in our corner glad to be here all
right we'll talk with you afterward
after the show actually cuz that to
clear things with
[Music]
all right now all right hear ye hear ye
this week's double secret patriarchy
meeting is now in session all presents
say aye
wonderful now first item up for
discussion we've heard a lot of
rumblings from angry women men we're
looking for ways to preserve our
secretive yet long-standing rape culture
any ideas anyone come now don't be shy
yes charlie yo what if like when a woman
wants to accuse a man of rape like like
whatever came up it made like a whole
court system thing we're like you know
to require some sort of verifiable proof
by hiding rape culture under the guise
of innocent until proven guilty
yea my lord that's brilliant charlie
yeah yeah it could be like a whole thing
with it well a judge judges in like like
due process process a foolproof system
designed to preserve our rape culture
without fail hair tight those [ __ ]
won't know what hit them fantastic work
Tom Tom you know that we are supposed to
keep refreshments to a to poor attendee
maximum see if you encountered the broom
if you had counted the room if you went
in the research is I than the research
you would know they're not cookies
[Music]
[Music]
after we held my breath that time I
don't know why been doing all those
breath exercises breathe in breathe out
Center yourself yes thank you so much
for everyone who's been watching and
supporting us listen like I said we
never want to be those people who just
just complained so we want to fill you
in on what it is we're doing and why and
we always want to be you know the always
be closing the equipment to that for us
is entertaining informative enlightening
if it's not informative it's not
enlightening it better be entertaining
think about that when it comes to the
left usually the left is guilty of
trying to force reality to be on what
they want it to be and this is one area
where conservatives tend to do that more
so when it comes to the way it's all
about the message them and they don't
consider the medium yeah and just like
if you want to change ideas you have to
change culture if you want to speak to
culture their language is entertainment
the problems conservatives always talk
about that but then soon so listen III
hope you guys have come along with me
and you know I've earned the right to
just sort of open myself up to you a
little bit earlier I know and I know it
got a little heated but I'm gonna
continue that we've huge show obviously
March 22nd next week next week we have a
ton of content anyway we have so much
more content there maybe a show Monday
or there may not because of legal issues
we hate to say that so stay posted if
you're Mudd Club member but I do want to
thank everyone real who support us it's
been overwhelming let me get one thing
you wanted to clarify with Twitter
the reason I'm banned for a week by the
way is because I was banned for 12 hours
just like Nike Jared and fan for sharing
the video and all of you who've shared
the video were banned for at least 12
hours the reason I was banned for a week
was because I got subsequent infractions
for scheduled tweets on my account of
that video which by the way once I was
banned for 12 hours
you couldn't unschedule you couldn't
possibly unschedule there was no way for
me to access the account so was soom
infraction 12 hours okay well let me go
in and unschedule you can't you're
locked out boom number two infraction
which we tried to remove there are so
many in their system it's not just this
victim complex from conservatives listen
the truth is sometimes your content
sucks sometimes you play out you up you
play a full song from Abbey Road and
it's not under parity you're breaking
the law
right I understand that um and we don't
do that we really do try and cross our
T's and dot our eyes here and it's been
a stressful week it's been a really
stressful week I think I've been doing
better at handling it than I used to I
think everyone here has done an amazing
job handling it
mark as new Johnny boy has made a big
difference on hire here helping keep
things organized that's why we're able
to create more content because I was
having to manage this stuff the business
side of things and it's grown beyond my
control so having people like though
this is this is a team effort
and I was actually fine enough was
really this week was really so I looked
when we had this thing to give you an
idea just to give you an idea to try and
I guess to try and make it relatable
because I know not everyone is you know
works in media and not everyone really
relies and social media is kind of just
some of those for fun for us it's the
lifeblood of 15 employees right it's the
lifeblood of knock' Jarrett of spent
computer I've ever to the sound guy of
Johnny boy of of Courtney of Casey of
Brautigan of mark of Garrett of Aaron
the intern and there's some frantic and
there's so many people and we just lost
Nicole last week we talked about that so
it is it's it's the lifeblood of all
this and I was pretty stressed so
imagine you wake up one morning whatever
it is that you do and you wake up that
morning and you're number two tool
Twitter has been removed from you your
number 2 business tool let's say you run
another you run a business and your
factory just shut down
there's no power to it it's the
equivalent to that and then you find out
an hour later you just didn't know about
it that your number one tool has been
taken away from you or certainly it's on
the way out because the video was
removed for a violation that you don't
know you made and you have no way to fix
it so your biggest distributor says no
go well you say well second line we have
a contract for nope we're negging that's
what it felt like that morning it was
and I'm not in war I do not compare it
to what soldiers go through believe me I
am NOT there are different levels of
intensity and sadness I'm just trying to
explain to you what it is it felt like
it was very intense it's trying to think
how can we fix this
get in the phone with Bill that same day
we still did a show
to show every single day this week we
still did shows and we're still going to
do it next week we have a big show on
the road with the drive long ways in a
van to SMU and then we have Illinois the
following week I would advertise it but
it's already full la doors kind of come
a slash tor tor tor live and I was
really stressed and trying to everyone
send us keep up appearances
and I walked in we had to shoot that
shining parody that you guys just saw
it's a great job again from the team and
Garrett who's one of the latest hires is
an intern can't say enough good things
about Garrett that his attitude Garrett
is a can-do guy listen I don't think it
would be that Garrett is new
Garrett isn't as seasoned so there are a
lot of things he can't quite do yet as
well as some of the more technical hire
ease but Garrett is on top of things a
big part of our studio reorganization I
mean this guy he worked at a he worked
at a cinema and he came in and he he
brought up the term cable configuration
and he builds props and he did the scar
tissue for the makeup on on the
waterfront
it's just hey Garrett can you help me
with this and before you finish the
phrase he's out doing it I can't say
enough good things about Garrett as a
person and he's been doing incredibly
well as an employee we're still finding
the best he's from that's one thing yet
to do as a leader to is find people's
strengths and try to use them to the
best of their ability it's hard to do
when you don't know what your work is
when you don't know what your product is
when you don't know what your
distribution is because people keep
taking it away from you um and we were
about to shoot the shining deal when I
was getting into wardrobe and I looked I
saw Garrett he was going like this and I
put my hand I said hey they said hey
Garrett man what's are you okay you seem
stressed he said no no I'm good he said
you know I'm just stressed his stresses
you know everyone is that's why you
don't need to be stressed no it's just
I'm stressed for you and it really it
was one of those things where it touched
me because I realized you know it
doesn't just this isn't about me these
guys they depend on me but they know
that after this day they can go work
somewhere else I've closed every door in
my face deliberately I can't go work
somewhere else and Garrett actually sent
me a member that night he sent me uh
sorry just again this is this is being
open with you proverbs three five six
trust in Lord with all thine heart and
lean not unto thine own understanding
and all the ways acknowledge him and he
shall direct thy paths he sent it that
night this is a new guy who we hi
who was genuinely stressed because he
cared about me and I know I felt that
way for other people on this team and I
know that a lot of you out there we get
your letters feel that way and you feel
as you let us into your room you let us
into your home at night a lot of you
watch it on TV and you say I really feel
like there's a connection you know I
really feel like I'm alone out there and
it made me you know there's a lot of
stress with this it's not about Twitter
it's not about Facebook it's not about
trolling stop being responsible for the
livelihoods of 15 people and it also
made me realize you know what we're
gonna fight this as hard as we can but I
know that people here understand that if
we fight as hard and we we lose it's
okay it's okay because we all know that
we're putting when you know that you've
put in as much effort as you possibly
can and you and you still you come up
short it's a tough pill to swallow but
it is one that you can swallow one you
can't swallow is say ah I could have
done this or I knew I should have
changed that it was just one of those
moments I looked at him and he was
stressed there was really no reason for
him to be stressed listen carrot Garrett
has been effectively an intern he's a
new guy he does everything that we need
him to do but he's not dealing with
lawyers he wasn't on the conference
calls all day with Bill and sending out
cease and desist lawyers and trying to
make sure that the show at SMU happens
he didn't have to deal with that stress
but he helped burden it for me and I
think I've seen him do it with other
people in office I've seen not gay
Jarrod do it I've seen I've seen Erin
the intern I've seen Courtney do it I've
seen every single person in this office
do it at some point and I've seen every
single person out there do it at some
point for other people in the movement
it's bigger than me it's bigger than the
team and you don't if you know if you
want to rip stuff off for free on Pitt
torn or whatever you can do that we've
tried to just make the content valuable
enough that you want to support us and
if you support us I think we made it
pretty clear that we're not going away
we're gonna be fighting harder and
harder and the reason we're able to do
it is because this is a very different
team the hiring process you know Nicole
we decided let go that was 500
applicants for her but the golden ticket
500 applicants and she had to leave
because she was sick she was very sick
and thank you so much again the people
who reached out doctors have reached out
to her and specialists and she
apologized to me because she felt like
she was a part of something special and
I feel like I'm a part of something
special getting to know these people
work with these people that's
why we have bill on retainer and by the
way there was a time when we were so
inundated with thee that that bill did
work for us for free the guy top
business lawyer in the state did work
for us for free because he said ok I get
it and I you take care of them you take
care of the money when you take care of
it I got this for you and that goes from
an SMU Law grad top of hit top of the
line half-asian skilled guy all the
degrees that you could look at on a
resume and be impressed with it goes
from that to the most recent intern we
hired every single person at some point
in this company in this movement says
that's ok I got it
and that really touched me a lot this
week so I've been stressed but I know
we're gonna get through it you know he
sent me some he sent me that proverb and
I sent him back I'll leave you with this
because this has always been actually my
favorite Bible verse and it's something
when we talk about guided meditation or
people have their mantra you know most
of that is silly but I had this in my
old office I actually have written on a
piece of paper I think when I mount it
over my wall and hopefully I know a lot
of people you're not dealing with
Twitter you're not dealing with you too
but everyone has their fights
everyone has their fight to deal with I
know that your struggle it may be way
bigger may it could be cancer could be
something going on with a relative who's
sick it could be maybe you don't know
where your next paycheck is coming from
I understand that what we have is not as
big of a deal as a lot of you believe me
this is not some kind of a victim
complex what I'm saying is I appreciate
that we're able to do this with you and
I appreciate that you going through your
own [ __ ] and don't censor that for me
you going through the [ __ ] that I know
you're going through I know I get your
letters I get them I don't get to read
all of them but even if I just scan
through a few dozen a day I get them I
know what you're going through I know it
sucks and the fact that you choose to
support us the fact that you choose to
be a part of this
I cannot that's why we never just go out
and go oh look at our look at all of our
place no no no I say oh my God look look
at all these plants look at look at
where we are look at how much we've
grown look at how we are being targeted
and hit my knees with gravity because we
could just as easily be inconsequential
you could be going through your crap and
choose not to make the time for so thank
you thank you so much and I'll leave you
with this my favorite verse for whatever
it is that you're going through is Psalm
144 I'm gonna go King games going on
school I think that's more
blessed be the Lord my strength teaches
my hands to war and my fingers to fight
and the wars about to start it's gonna
get ugly really appreciate you being
with us we'll see you next week maybe
live SMU March 22nd
[Music]